hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now i'm coming to
you from the interval here in san
francisco
where i will be joined by our speaker
tonight jason tester
to watch the pre-recorded version of his
talk along with answering questions from
you all afterwards
jason is a foresight researcher with the
institute for the future here in san
francisco
and has recently been exploring where
futurism sexual orientation and identity
meet
tonight he is going to give us a taste
of that research and show us how looking
at the future through an lgbtq lens can
help benefit
us all welcome jason tester
thank you xander thank you for all for
having me here at long now
um as andrew said i am jason and i'm on
a 20-year journey to make sense of my
queerness which has been a part of my
life for about that long i've also been
a professional futurist for about the
same amount of time 20 years
and to prove it to you here's an aged
image of what it might look like at age
60.
now i've long suspected that these two
halves of my life weren't a coincidence
and i think i've now discovered why and
i'm excited to really share that with
you tonight
i'm trusting most of the long now
audience will know the basic terms of
sexual orientation and gender identity
that i'll be using today but i do want
to define the word queer
because we really can't start talking
about it until i do so what is queer
well as an adjective queer describes all
the sexual and gender identities other
than straight and cisgender
so lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
people may all identify with the word
queer
queer is sometimes used to express that
sexuality and gender can be complicated
can change over time and might not fit
neatly into either or identities like
male or female
gay or straight so when i say quit the
future i mean in two ways and this first
way is based around queer the adjective
and that's i want to identify the future
forces that will disproportionately
disrupt
the lives of lgbtq people over the next
20 to 30 years
i want to center our lives in foresight
research and futures narratives
and especially to imagine interventions
to at least rebalance these imbalance
impacts as one example of a foresight
question i'm working with
how will caregiving assistance and aging
and place technologies deal with lgbtq
people in their relationships
it won't come as a shock to learn that
lgbt elders are much more likely to have
not had children
up to three to four times more likely
but even today
20 of lgbt older adults say they have no
one to call
in a time of crisis that is ten times
the general elderly population
and a mere eight percent of senior
housing centers offer services targeted
at lgbt older adults we're already deep
in a caregiving crisis between supply
and need
it's likely that lgbtq people will need
technologies of care
more than any other demographic another
question i'm exploring
is will ai and other intelligence
systems built with cisgender
heterosexual training data
constantly reinforce the gender binary
imagine bathrooms in the future
particularly in conservative areas or
regions of the world
equipped with vision recognition that
scan for biological markers
or stereotypical gender expressions
before they would actually admit someone
it's not hard to imagine a future where
more of us are living as gender fluid
while surrounded by by binary bias
machine intelligence programmed without
any exposure to other expressions or
experiences of gender
and last but not least there's the big
stuff that will affect us all
a study that came out last may
discovered that in a business's
usual climate scenario in the absence of
migration
one-third of the global population is
projected to experience a mean
annual temperature of greater than or
equal to 29 degrees celsius and that's
about 84 degrees fahrenheit
which is currently only found in about
8.8 of the earth's land surface and
that's mostly concentrated in the sahara
so the report goes on to say
specifically 3.5 billion people will be
exposed to a mean annual temperature of
greater than or equal to 29 degrees
celsius
living in a sahara-like climate i've
read that and that's a shocking
statistic it's truly hard to comprehend
but since i've been doing this work i
now take 10 of these impossibly large
numbers
to understand the impact on people who
are likely to identify in the coming
decades as queer
or not totally heterosexual so we take
that same sentence and we querify it
and we get specifically 350 million
queer people will be exposed to mean
annual temperatures
greater than or equal to 29 degrees
celsius now
3.5 billion people living in a
sahara-like climate is likely to yield
severe constraints of vital resources
and overall miserable
conditions but now imagine being queer
transgender
living in this newly inhospitable
climate that's located in a region of
the planet that's already inhospitable
to your very existence life in that in
that scenario sounds pretty hellish
another report last year was projected
that up to 1.2 billion people could be
displaced
by climate change by 2050 by mid-century
now i think applying the same queer math
that's the same headline reads
climate crisis could displace 120
million queer people
now my goal when i query these numbers
isn't to advocate for my people at the
expense of other groups
or to create an us versus them mentality
but it's simply to call out that large
areas of the planet are rapidly becoming
doubly inhospitable to queer lives who
should have equal rights
to the human universals of love
happiness and true expression
in the coming decades we are likely to
face mass migration at nearly
unimaginable levels
but also unprecedented research scarcity
and triage
and ultimately an inability to provide
the necessities of life for everyone
that needs them
so here are a couple of couple concrete
examples of this
according to the u.n 5 billion people
could have poor access to fresh water by
and as early as 2030 global water demand
is expected to outstrip supply by 40
and lastly the u.n estimates that the
planet will need twice as much food in
2050 as it does today
while grain yields decline as
temperatures increase
now i know that these aren't uniquely
lgbtq issues
but they're likely to disproportionately
affect queer people given current
statistical realities
like this 27 of lgbt adults
experienced food insecurity in the prior
year compared to only 17
of non-lgbt adults and 22 percent of u.s
of lgbt people in the u.s live in
poverty compared to only 16 percent
so given these disproportionate
statistical realities today
it's very likely that they'll be they
will extend into the future and we'll
see these same
disproportionate impacts going forward
so if distribution of critical resources
is already this out of balance when we
don't when we when we have plenty of
food and water to go around today
imagine a world where we don't i hope
lgbtq people will fare equally
but i truly fear we won't the purpose of
my life has now become if we are indeed
all going extinct
let's go extinct together as equals
which brings me to my the first thesis
of queering the future
and i believe that we as a queer and
allied community have one generation
roughly 20 to 30 years
to achieve a basic floor of lgbtq
respect and dignity across the planet
before things get truly unambiguously
critically dire for billions of people
and this must be a widespread lived
reality found in the majority of hearts
and minds of a culture
not just toothless legislative
proclamations i mean not just
would you let your bisexual neighbor
borrow some of your water rations for
her family
would you offer your trans customer
shelter from the heat or your gaydis and
cousin a seat in your raft
unfortunately that scenario of mass
acceptance seems unlikely in the
relatively short timeframe demanded of
it
and a scary prospect for hundreds of
millions of lgbtq adults
and young adults if you don't achieve it
but perpetually looming right around the
corner is another potential
existential threat to my people last
year the largest study of the biology of
homosexuality was conducted
using genetic data from 23andme and the
uk biobank so about 500 000 participants
total their conclusion was
that some genes can account for about
one-third of the influence
over whether someone has ever had
same-sex sex at least once in their
lives
but not all geneticists supported this
research many in the lgbt affinity group
of the very institute leading this study
were opposed including a colleague of
the research leader who said
in part i have yet to see a compelling
argument that the potential benefits of
this study outweigh is potential harms
and indeed every year and i've been
studying the biology of sexuality for
years
there are new groundbreaking studies
there are also ongoing investigations
into epigenetic mechanisms of sexuality
and a potential connection to hormonal
conditions in the womb
we're doing a decen if slow job at
banning so-called gay
cures now these are deeply harmful
psychological treatments
passing off as beneficial therapies but
what if a gay vaccine became possible
cheaply at scale available for everyone
i'll grant you this is a wild card
scenario low probability but
speaking as a queer man myself very
extremely high impact
but please keep watching after i say
this but i cannot totally dismiss the
notion that a gay
vaccine would be all bad it might offer
the potential to eliminate the suffering
of hundreds of millions of lgbtq people
not yet born
especially in regions that are likely to
become inhospitable to queerness
and which happen to be those regions
becoming literally inhospitable to
humanity itself
to be clear it wasn't lost on me that i
might be turning into a queer man
considering eugenics against his own
people
but i am deeply afraid for our future
between the prospect of a century of
triaging water and food
for hundreds of millions of queer people
while seeming closer than ever to true
understanding of the biology of
homosexuality
i'll admit that these are deep-seated
existential fears
but i also need to flip that fear which
leads me to my second meaning
of queer of the future queer can also be
used as a verb and this definition is
proposed by charlie glickman
as he proposed fundamentally querying is
an active ongoing transformation
both within ourselves and in relation to
the world around us to queer something
is to take a look at its foundations and
question them
we can explore its limits its biases its
boundaries we can look for places where
there is elasticity
or discover ways where we can transform
it into something new
to queries to examine our assumptions
and decide which of them we want to keep
change discard or play with so i started
asking
does queerness confer any sort of
advantage especially for the wild future
world we're headed towards
what even is queerness beyond the theory
that we help the tribe raise kids
despite or maybe because of all the
trauma and marginalization that can come
from being born queer
and any family in any city in any
country in the world have we created
something in our culture found in the
periphery
and underground that has been waiting
for this moment what if queer culture
itself
with someone with some surprising human
universals across the globe
is itself a cultural evolutionary
mutation ready to confer advantages of
survival and resilience in the
larger population the core irony of
course
that these traits are sourced from a
group of people who cannot reproduce
themselves
but may be able to help humanity as a
whole adapt and thrive into the future
which leads me to thesis number two and
that's that the queer perspective is
made up of some surprisingly shared
traits and tendencies
that will be useful for societies and
people to thrive in the coming decades
ahead
put another way queerness can keep
things cool in hotter futures
today i've identified five traits that
can answer both of these questions
what is queerness and what mindsets and
practices will confer success
in the future we're likely headed
towards a queer future could be more
than it is today
more transformative more equitable hell
even more fabulous for everyone with a
touch of a queer eye
or maybe it's actually the future itself
that's already becoming more queer
and all of us need to play catch-up i
can be your guide like
virgil in the inferno or the mc from
cabaret
or any one of the hosts from queer eye
all rolled into one
of course queerness is more than these
five traits and success in the future
will require more skills than
this list but i hope seeing queerness in
the future in conversation together like
this
spark some novel insights for about how
you approach the future the lenses and
biases that we all bring to our
forecasting
so think of this as a guide to how to
queer the future
and step number one is to question
prevailing systems
queerness fundamentally exists in
opposition to arguably the most
prevailing system in the human condition
which is heterosexual reproduction
in fact the dna of queerness is
suspicion or outright rejection of norms
orthodoxy and continuation scenarios
because norms and continuation typically
kept us miserable or dead
for millennia a default to question the
unquestionable is a strong foundation
to readily envision transformative
alternatives and original ways of doing
and being
jose esteban munoz wrote cruising utopia
just as the light at the end of the
tunnel was shining
towards the the end of the aids epidemic
and we could begin to see queerness
again
for for its positivity and for its
hopefulness
and he wrote queerness is essentially
about the rejection of a here
now and on potentiality or concrete
possibility
for another world and this is an
infamous pamphlet that was passed out
by act up in the 1990 new york a pride
parade
being queer means leading a different
sort of life it's not about the
mainstream prophet margins patriotism
patriarchy or being assimilated
it's not about executive directors
privilege and elitism it's about being
on the margins
defining ourselves well many of us first
heard of
prison and police abolition this summer
with many of the black lives matter
riots
um resisting and questioning the
dominant systems of
of police and incarceration in the
cultural state have long been in the dna
of queerness itself
going all the way back to the 1966
compton's cafeteria riots here in san
francisco
or three years later uh at the root of
the stonewall riots which was an
anti-police demonstration
and as noted activists dr angela davis
has pointed out as
is true for so much of queer history it
was transgender people who actually
pointed the way
to this resistance dr davis says we
support the trans community precisely
because the trans community has taught
us
how to challenge that which is totally
accepted as normal if it is possible to
challenge the gender binary
we can certainly effectively resist
prisons and police
now coming out is also a form of
questioning the prevailing systems
by choosing to come out queer people go
through a process they start a personal
journey that consciously places them
on the margins of what is quantitatively
mainstream and that comes with a
double-edged sword
you no longer have an autopilot the same
as many of your straight heterosexual
friends do
and rather than being superfluous to
change the margins are in fact
the foundry of the future where
societies innovate and grow
so they're very active coming out the
very act of declaring yourself a queer
person
is itself questioning the mainstream
system and starting to make the future
in a new way
our second step in how to query the
future is about rejecting binaries and
binary thinking most forecasts of work
and life in the future
imagine greater fluidity in our
identities our preferences
self-expression and our communications
and interactions
but queerness found comfort with nuance
outside of categories early on
simply because we've been forced to
craft our own alternatives to most
institutions in society
queer adaptations to the binaries of
married or single or family or friend
or even our own internal compasses of
attraction and gender in each moment
often begin like all novel futures as
outliers if not considered fully deviant
then certainly not accepted by the
mainstream
before time passes they're reconsidered
for their benefits and suddenly have
widespread appeal
let's say let's take the gender binary
for example the gender binary is so
entrenched in our lives
that we will literally explode the world
to reinforce it
these are scenes from gender binary real
parties over the past year in which
couples dramatically reveal the gender
of their child
through a pink or blue substance such as
exploding smoke
the binary is so reinforced that so many
couples have taken this to an extreme
with their reveals
inadvertently lighting tens of thousands
of acres on fire
now that biology does not equal identity
often gets lost in the spectacle
binary defi binary defenders have
crashed planes
enlisted alligators backfired trucks and
gotten into fights at and kicked out of
applebee's
and most unfortunately once exploded a
pipe bomb into a guest's skull
killing her instantly as the atlantic
put it
how many people have to die before we're
done with gender reveals and i would ask
with gender itself
another example of resisting binaries uh
comes from us from
sex columnist dan savage and his term
that he coined
about 10 years ago called monogamish and
he coined this term to describe the
arrangement that he has with his husband
for
occasional extramarital sex with other
people and the rules and
the requirements that go with that
condition savage was aiming to create a
more realistic sexual ethic that would
prize honesty a little
flexibility and unnecessary forgiveness
something to live between promiscuity
and monogamy which savage considers
right for many but unnatural for most
and and so again another queer
adaptation to
a true heteronormative binary
i could have put up many headlines here
to show
just how queer the younger generations
are proving to be
than their older counterparts teens
these days are queer
af studies says only 48 of gen z's
identify as exclusively heterosexual
compared to 65 of millennials age 21 to
34.
those belonging to generation z also
rejected the gender binary while
shopping
only 44 said they always bought clothes
designed for their own gender
versus 54 of millennials so
as we can see the gender binary at least
with these new younger generations
is falling fast our next step in our
journey to how to query the future
is connect intersectionally now this
really starts from an
assumption that a more egalitarian and
broadly prosperous future
seems difficult to achieve if we can't
agree to live and interact
in both deep diversity and deep harmony
with each other
as simple as it sounds working at
widespread scale to acknowledge and
understand that the living experiences
of people from different backgrounds
will be different is a very hard notion
for many people to truly grasp
including others experiences of
discrimination and privilege
particularly realities of people of
color
but also the lives of those with
disabilities and people with fewer means
than ourselves
this content is known as
intersectionality while relatively
simple to convey
and can be very difficult to put into
practice but without this basic floor of
mutual respect and acceptance we may not
survive
intersectionality is arguably the most
important skill for us making it into
the future
if so many of our most talented
community members hold back from their
true selves
their full creativity their full joy and
passion from the
from the unprecedented task we face
remaking the world because the fullness
of their identities feels unwelcome
we do not get all of the ideas that we
need to make it into the next world
this is where i have to be the first to
admit that queerness and particularly
white queerness
is far from perfect at making this
future our reality the first super gay
rights groups
formed after stonewall were deeply
intersectional and multiracial
and many argue that the recent focus on
gay marriage took us away from the more
important issues of economic and
employment equity
as one signal that the queer community
is trying to require its own future
we've amended the pride flag to
acknowledge and center the lives
and importance of queer people of color
in our movement adding black and brown
stripes on top of the already seven
color rainbow
one way in which queer people as a
community do have an advantage is
through the shared advantage of
marginalization
one experience of marginalization
predisposes you to under a greater
understanding
of compound marginalizations that other
people may face
one way to think about intersectionality
as it is as a tool for augmented empathy
empathy of course will be a vital skill
in this increasingly crowded
automated and unequal polarized and
mediated centuries so far
understanding the way another person
encounters the world accepted or shunned
by their peers bosses and strangers
is a deeply human act now as we're
talking about practicing
intersectionally i want to make a bit of
a side note here to say that i firmly
believe that the future of the future
is being created by transgender women of
color and gender non-binary people of
color
and that we should all trust their
leadership particularly those those of
us in the queer community
i can't highly recommend enough the
documentary the future of trans by amara
jones
and the trans agenda for liberation's
call to action to grow your
understanding of their deeply
intersectional lives
additionally the exciting intersectional
futurism of people like lonnie brooks
who's pioneering afro career futures and
who's long now talk you can easily
google and watch
our next step in how to query the future
is one very much related to
some fundamentals of queerness embracing
pleasure and joy
historically queerness has long
prioritized feelings of pleasure and joy
as indicators
of happiness and well-being far far
before modern medicine
accepted their value but not just
medicinally
queerness has spoken of these as
essential precursors
to unspeakable heights of creativity and
uninhibited ideation
basically from foundations to imagining
radically new futures but even this had
become taboo since queer pleasure queer
pleasure was deeply stigmatized when
lgbtq people were fighting battles on
multiple fronts
against aids and for equal equal access
to mainstream institutions like the
right to marry and adopt the fundamental
sexuality of queerness
went away to for many people to fight
respect
find respectability in the mainstream
society
but this is starting to come back in in
movements like pleasure activism
pleasure activism is the organized
struggle to re-prioritize bliss
and sensuality to build individual and
collective resilience
and ultimately as a necessary foundation
to conjure better worlds
i'd like to share this quote from
pleasure activism author adrienne marie
brown
you're not going to forget the suffering
in the world just because you had a
great orgasm
you're going to have more resilience for
turning and facing that suffering
if you're also in touch with a part of
your life that feels amazing and not
just the total catastrophes that are
happening
or as our favorite queer futurist of all
time jose esteban munoz put it in
cruising utopia
some will say that all we have are the
pleasures of this moment but we must
never settle for that minimal transport
we must dream and enact new and better
pleasures other ways of being in the
world and ultimately new worlds
which this quote really fascinates me as
someone who is always trying to come up
with new ideas and new
and new transformative more accurate
futures more wild futures
that what if we actually based what
based that not on technology not on
pro on gdp not on value but on pleasure
and really our goal was to find new
pleasure in new
and new futures that really excites me
and our last step in how to create a
future is
hustling between worlds so for a long
time
to find companionship and work with
neither were available to us in
mainstream society queer folks for
millennia
have been re perceiving and repurposing
spaces and platforms
to seek their hidden layers latent gigs
and the underground social networks
when any form of traitor hustling
existed on the margins of respectable
society
queerness pioneered this this rhythm of
finding ad hoc
latent opportunity the hustle that now
truly defines the future
work for food love everything on demand
if you know where and how to look
only recently has proficiency of the
hustle and juggling multiple hustles
become an admired ability
by now you've heard of used or as you're
watching me are also getting
notifications
from a location-based smartphone app but
grindr for gay men started it all
launched less than two years after the
iphone grinder was an instantly
game-changing tool for the hustle
and changed the future of online dating
rather than congregating in bars to find
romance and limited by who else happened
to be there
grinder gave you the superpower to stay
home and see the previously invisible
layer of other guys near you
grandeur didn't invent mobile social
networking but it certainly did set an
early model for how we come to see our
think of our phones
as secret decoders revealing the latent
possibilities surrounding us
for everything from car rental to food
delivery to romance
futurist madeline ashby who has done a
great deal of
speculative work and recently wrote how
to future
um has this passage that i love that
captures a lot about
the relationships between hustling in
the future she writes
for a long time the future has belonged
to people who have not had to struggle
and i think that will still be true but
as more and more systems collapse
currency energy the ability to get water
the ability to work
the future will increasingly belong to
those who know how to hustle
and those people are not the people who
are producing those purely optimistic
futures
the future belongs to those who know how
to hustle and mj patrony
a local queer futurist and ux designer
in an interview he talked about what he
values looking for in queer employees
we often look for people who have
existed in lots of different worlds
and walking back and forth between these
spaces and never being fully at home
they learn a lot about the unspoken
rules and assumptions and codes and
values that exist
so i really want to try to answer the
question in these five trades
how can querying the future solve our
most we get problems how can querying
the future
help anybody and i hope that across
these five skills of traits that show
that
queer folks across countries and
millennia have demonstrated a nimble
resilience
prosperity for adaptation and
resourcefulness a
healthy skepticism and embrace for other
worlds a continual if far from perfect
practice of deep
empathy that keeps us striving to do
better
and a widespread acceptance of the
connection between our biologies
and our desires and achieving our
destinies under any conditions
but on an even deeper level we won't
achieve transformative solutions to our
most critical problems
using the same legacy tools that we've
used in the past
we need everyone to bring their ideas
and engagement to bear on the complexity
complexity of the future yet 1.5 billion
people currently live in 72 countries
where homosexuality is illegal
and billions more live in countries
without widespread cultural acceptance
and we know that being your full self
makes a difference in your participation
and your citizenship in a
society or in a workplace as one example
the boston consulting group has found
that the ability to be out at work
helps workers feel twice as much
psychological safety and one and a half
times more
empowered and free to take creative
risks
imagine imagine imagine the other
freedoms that billions of people
lose being in the closet around the
world every single day
but setting aside productivity or
innovation on any measure
i want to end on this statistic which i
learned
last year and has really become one of
my north stars
researchers at the family acceptance
project at san francisco state
university
one question they're asked is do you
believe that you will ever be
a happy lgbt adult for queer youth who
come from families rated extremely
accepting
92 percent 92 are able to imagine
themselves in happy futures
for queer youth from families who who
outright shun
or reject them only 35 have this ability
think about that for a minute two-thirds
of lgbtq young people
who had the misfortune to be born to
families that cannot accept them
have lost the ability to imagine their
future selves being happy
i can't see how losing that ability is
any different from losing one's
fundamental sense of hope
hope for themselves hope for the world
hope for their for
their individual future or ours
collectively so it's phenomenal like
this
that happened every day anywhere an
lgbtq kid is growing up
knowing that they're different afraid to
express it even in the most progressive
regions let alone the most conservative
that motivates me to keep queering the
future and showing that the future can
be queer
to create more scenarios with thriving
queer protagonists to uncover the trends
that will particularly impact lgbtq
people
not just to preempt emerging victimhood
but also to empower them to grab the
wheel
and grab us by the future they see and
deserve
to learn more about any of the lgbt
foresight research that i presented
today please check out the research home
at queerthefuture.org
this has been me so far with the help of
a lot of friends and experts and
and people have smarter people i'm
talking to but i would love this to be a
home where anyone
anyone who identifies as a queer future
as a trans future so not a non-binary
futurist
anywhere in the world can come and can
share their ideas and we can create
collective visions for how we want our
lives and our communities to live
in the future thank you very much
thank you so much jason um this was
really amazing to have you
um i'm joining us tonight um from
my home just because of the heightened
state of of things
in the pandemic but thank you for
joining us live from the interval
tonight so that you can answer some of
the questions that are coming in from
our stream thank you so much for being
here
happy to be here great awesome um well i
hope you enjoyed uh seeing the version
of your talk i'd love to just get into
some of the questions that that i had
you know i think one of the possibly the
most provocative statement that you have
in here
um is this idea of the queer vaccine
which you know obviously vaccines
couldn't be more on the forefront of
all of our minds at the moment but i
don't think that's the one that people
were thinking of
uh being being used and that and you
know obviously how provocative that is
from a eugenics standpoint
so i'd love for you to just kind of
unpack that a little bit more as to
you know i think what you were trying to
say is that there are people in places
in the world that are so persecuted
that it could actually help suffering
for those people and
and that you can't take it off the table
for people that might be killed because
of their
their queerness pretty much i mean every
every year our understanding of of the
of the genetics of homosexuality of
sexuality in general
um our understanding of of genetic
technologies in general
increases and every every year every two
years we
see the results of a giant massive study
looking at trying to identify the gay
gene
um and we're getting closer to the point
where we haven't identified the gay gene
yet we think it may be multiple genes um
but it's that it's that i we hint at it
in the video it's this idea that
um there could be a mechanism by which
we never have to identify the gay gene
um but we can identify what affects that
gene
um for example uh every
for every male fetus that was in a womb
before the next one
uh that that next fetus has a 33 chance
greater chance of being born
gay um so that we know there's something
about the hormonal
uh changes and positioning and balance
in the womb
um that can if that affects sexuality uh
so my concern i mean this is a great
this is a wild card uh you know low
probability but
very high impact um my is that we don't
need to
spend fifty thousand dollars to edit out
the gauging
fetus by fetus but we could actually
just we could work around that never
identify the
the gene itself but just prevent it from
activating
if what if that was a dollar a day
supplement
uh for a pregnant person um you know
to have a to reduce the chance of having
a queer kid by 50
or greater um i mean that was one of the
first
putting all those that two and two
together was one of the first times i
felt i felt i felt kinship with my
community i felt
it was it was i felt a bit of kind of
existential uh existential communal
kinship really like we could we could go
extinct
uh what is there about i mean there have
been evolutionary biology theories about
why homosexuality
for forever that we help raise the kids
that uh we are we are supplemental
parents that we
uh mediate we mediate the tribe
um but what if it were to just what if
it were to disappear
what if we had the ability to make it
disappear um i think there's a lot of cr
and this is the genesis of the research
i think there's a lot of queerness
that's worth saving
indeed and i think to your point i mean
when
sonograms became available in um in
certain countries and regions that that
you know basically um kind of exalt male
children
um we've seen the the female birth rate
fall through the floor
um and so you know there's there's
already kind of these levels of using
technology for a eugenic or a
societal kind of desire um and so
you certainly could imagine in places
where countries
that are so violent and uh marginalized
for um for queerness that those parents
may choose to not have a queer child for
sure
and and to the way you frame the
question would
is preventing a a queer child from being
born in one of those conservative places
is that actually an act
of compassion um from actually from
i mean i can't i can't dismiss that
possibility right and you can imagine
parents making it from that point that
place in their heart
um not from yeah obviously from a place
of
i think you know misunderstanding of
what it is but also but truly
understanding how difficult that kid's
life is going to be in their culture
that's why it's one of the even even
even in the most developed progressive
places it's one of the first
uh many parent many ask any queer person
uh and their parents one of their first
reactions will be when you come out
will be i just want you to i don't want
you to have a hard life
um and that's that's that's such a
universal reaction that parents have
upon coming out
it can only be when when you have the
potential to prevent that
in a place where that life would be so
tough
that's a that's a that's going to be a
tough bioethical
crossroads to to that we're facing no
and i think we're i mean we're going to
be facing this for
in all kinds of parts of genetic
engineering and we are you know as i
said there's already ways that we're
finding it out for gender
itself um i think you know but you know
and we're already you know
when you know my daughter was born they
gave us all these host of tests that we
could
test for to decide if we wanted to have
a kid of that had various diseases
um and so again from the compassion of
the parents position
they may want to choose to not have that
child um
and it's a it's but it it also kind of
it takes it takes this whole
realm of um of i think
um a variation out of the human
experience too which is i think you know
if all the kids were these blonde
blue-eyed perfect
you know eugenic you know kids that all
had the same gender preference and
and non-queerness then you know i don't
think that's the the world that we
actually want to live in
truly right yeah i agree
no i think to that point i i think um
you know and we're seeing now a much
more acceptance at least in certain
uh in certain cultures of queerness you
know things shows like queer eye having
such a huge
thing and rupaul's drag race being you
know this huge um
you know kind of success and emmy award
we're award-winning thing that
that there's clearly a huge acceptance
at least in certain cultures
that queerness and otherness bring so
much to our culture
that that they that these marginalized
groups
um can help our culture in so many ways
and i'm wondering what your thoughts are
on
why is it that the marginalized groups
can bring us so much creativity and so
much
um so much kind of fabulousness to our
to our culture
what is it about the marginalization
well as
as we hear in the in the video i think
there's when when you choose to come out
when you choose to life live the life
of that is you know let's say queerness
is five to ten percent of the population
right
um you are you are living your life
against the 90
of that main street um and it's a
double-edged sword you are
you no longer have the autopilot um that
many people have
um that were the obvious next decisions
i mean for you do i
well yes i naturally get married you
naturally have kids
but you also have so much more freedom
uh to
to chart your own path and i think to
try your own path to
uh explore ideas and arrangements
and these these spaces between binaries
that we talked about
um that would you when you're living
when you're living in the margins i mean
the
margins are really the the foundry
of creativity the founding of the future
and i think that's i think
a queer life just lends itself lends
itself naturally
to greater consideration greater uh
awareness of the choices that we're
making um
and and also greater experimentation
you know and i think you know uh our
previous speaker dr lonnie brooks who
was talking
about afrofutures as well as afro queer
features i think one of the things that
he pointed out that was really
eye-opening for me was this
this notion that um that uh
that black people have have had to be
futurist because their marginalized
present was so
so difficult that in a way they had to
project a better future for themselves
in order to
to kind of have a present that they
could live with and um i'm wondering is
do you feel as though that's a similar
thing for queer populations
i do i actually i i have a i believe
this is
a saying of mine uh but that queer
people actually
queer people make some of the best
futurists because for most of our lives
we've had to hope that tomorrow that
tomorrow will be better for us than
today
that we will be more respected more
welcome more accepted
um in the world of tomorrow the world of
next week in the world of next year
and then we have been today and we know
yes we're
our i'm losing my trajectory here but
yes we're making progress um but it is
it is scatter shot progress we are
you know often going two steps forward
one step back um we're not there yet
yeah and going back to some of the new
technologies i think you know some of
the new technologies that may be coming
in genetics
may allow you know you you said that you
know that some queer parents are seen as
this extra set of parents
um but um you know i think what's coming
um very obviously is that
there's already technologies where two
people of the same gender can
effectively generate
offspring or even you can generate
offspring based on only a single
person's
genetic material coming so do you think
that's going to change some of the
outlooks and the way the ways we parent
the way we think about parenting
i think it will and and what excites me
is that we uh that queer people may
actually be able to
uh perpetuate ourselves um no longer
that no longer being this this
this artifact or this this rare mutation
within the heterosexual population
within heterosexual reproduction
but that we could uh potentially
perpetuate queerness ourselves there's
a there's a fascinating study recently
um that
children i believe uh children or
daughters of
lesbian parents are more likely to be
have
to have had same sex experimentation uh
and that's the the theory the the the
why is still up for grabs of course
um but something that being raised by
queer parents chris
creates more of a space for for
for this experimentation for for
choosing choosing choosing your own for
following your own path following your
own preferences
and deciding what's right for you um
which is
is really exciting well certainly i mean
some of the statistics you're showing
between gen z and jen um you know the
current generation millennial generation
started the last chapter
gen z and uh the millennial generation
that there's the acceptance seems to
also be allowing for so many more people
to identify um
in a in a really profound way i mean
we're not you're close we're crossing
the 50
line of basically effectively gender for
um for people that that feel free to
identify as
as non-binary and part of it part of
that has been the terms
so i think as i understand that a lot of
young people have
almost a an allergic reaction to the
terms to the
to the first generation of terms lesbian
gay bisexual
transgender um as as as
the questions they're asked are they are
you are you gender fluid
are you have you are you not exclusively
heterosexual
as we talk more about these in between
categories and you don't have to fit
into one
distinct category or bucket with a with
a 50-year past 50-year legacy
making a huge declaration but just be
just be fluent to be open
that's when we're seeing these numbers
really climb
um from from the the five percent that
may be gay
um in older generations to the
50 who are identified as not
so as genderfluid or as not exclusively
a heterosexual
that all the way down to jet sea um so
it's it's delayed so language is a part
of it but also but really just an
understanding of this
of of spectrums and fluidity away from
the categories from first generation
we're certainly
we are at least in third fourth
generation
of of lgbt culture and life and activism
now and
it's it's it's i can't wait to see where
it goes
right well i want to come back to that a
little bit we also have a few questions
coming in and um the first one
from kevin kelly is organizing our
questions um and kind of to this point
of
do do you think science should guide
what we consider
queer or or should we should we let that
be a societal and a self
or a self um expression
if we identify this gene is that should
be the only thing that we rely upon
i i think i mean queer is square is such
a moving target
um i mean queer almost queer almost
always needs something
to exist in opposition against um
uh i mean you know queer is um
how to put it i mean queer needs a queer
really does need to be transgressive
um against against a prevailing system i
think i think that what is
the notion of what is queer will change
over time
um and i i
i think you know a identifying
identifying
the the gay gene identifying you know a
distinct
biology uh distinctive marker of
homosexual of
of awareness of homosexuality um
does not necessarily confer um
confirm all these traits and this is one
thing that one nuance that
hasn't come up yet is that queer is not
queer is not necessarily gay uh i mean
there are
queerness and the the lgb
lgbt uh is different than the queue in
many respects
um that queerness is queerness is a
is a form of fluid homosexuality that
that really exists i think in um
in active active conversation and active
um opposition to a lot of mainstreams
and these are these are some of the
traits that i was meaning to identify
we have that quickly these these
according not every uh lgbt person
can queer the future in the way that
someone who is truly who truly
identifies and embodies
queerness uh can so i think that's
that's an important distinction is
um really isolating what is what is
queerness what is it now what
what has it been um and can we
can we keep that kind of this
non-assimilationist
identity can can we keep that coming up
here we preserve that going forward
well that's interesting and i think you
know how this identity has kind of come
out
and been more accepted and you mentioned
things like the cafeteria and stonewall
riots which
um and and really how that it came from
the black
trans community that that really through
the first bricks and the windows
literally of this of this fight um but i
i also feel as though to a certain
extent they kind of got left behind in
the movement and they're we're just now
starting to see them coming forward
um in the conversation much more than i
think um
you know let's say white gay men um and
even you know
white lesbian women have have been able
to be accepted
and i'm not sure is that because they
could kind of pass in culture way more
than
obviously an a kind of an out black tray
trans
uh woman or man i mean i think
you know we have to look back at it look
back at intersectionality which we
talked about
i mean the intersection of racism
homophobia transphobia
um you know the a a a
a transgender person of color um you
know
female female center person of color
has a much has many many more um
uh you know against against the
mainstream
expectation going going for her
and so yeah i think i think look at look
at the student intersectional lens
um and those stats about poverty about
hunger that we that we pulled up
um for a lot of those stats you know
between um
they though those stats don't really
tell tell the entire picture between uh
let's say gay white men and straight
white men
um you know those disparities are
actually not um you know
whiteness is a lot of privilege um but
if you look at
you know the you know what percentage of
of of of black black queer or black
trans people live in poverty
then those numbers get so much higher
those that we're talking a third
or higher people live in poverty live in
hunger
so we're just we really need to unmap
and understand
the nuances within our community well i
think to that point you know we have a
question here from
uh from nick from youtube feed um
you mentioned you know that the kind of
percentages of families that are
more accepting and less accepting at
this point that luckily it seems to be
on largely on at least in american
culture on a good trajectory
but what about the research into the
ones that they kind of the 35 percent
who live in families that are
unaccepting but manage to stay accepting
like how
how are we how are we finding ways to
support those kids
and how are they finding support
themselves
yeah i mean something like uh a third i
i want to say
i mean which are the numbers here but a
third up to 40 percent
of homeless teens uh or young adults
are lgbt um versus what being
10 of them 10 roughly the population
so this is this is a real phenomenon and
luckily there are
there are a lot of of groups that are
focusing on
um you know queer kids queer kids where
teens
who are young adults who have been
rejected who are living on the streets
and trying to trying to specifically
solve
the the multiple intersecting problems
that they face
uh trying to get back on their feet
without family resources
i mean that's um the idea of the idea
of the chosen family uh is so important
to queer communities right
uh since so many parents so many so many
parents and my families are
are rejecting to some degree right
whether it's
don't bring your partner home for
christmas um
to don't ever don't ever come to my
house again
that the idea of the the notion of the
chosen family which is starting to
spread from
one of those innovations that sorry i
think starting queer culture and his
and is you know as has such benefit and
value that other people are
are adopting it um that the chosen
families is really important
is one of our survival adaptations and i
think survival
survival under many conditions is one
thing queerness
excels at i said uh we had one
clarification question that i'd love to
get from you is um
is what is what is a chosen family i
don't think everyone is understanding
that term
sure uh chosen family is so uh
parents you come out to your parents um
often
depending on where you live who your
parents how your parents were raised
is religion a part of the of the family
parents are often very rejecting
uh i know i every every lgbtq person
knows someone whose
family has essentially shunned them has
said do not
you are not welcome here they maybe talk
once a decade
um a chosen family is you know you you
move away from it's often rural
rural to big city um and these and
chosen family
are it's it's the people that are your
new family
it's the people that are they're a
hybrid of their their their friends
their former lovers
um they're they're the people that you
that you whose shoulders you cry on
um that you you know talk to that that
know your life story
uh it's it's it's friendship plus really
um it's and think of it think of it as a
um
who would you invite to thanksgiving if
if if not for your own family
uh i think is one thanks thanksgiving is
often where chosen family
really manifests who would be who would
be around
who would be around that very queer
table um
right well um i want to thank you very
much for this work and for giving this
talk we're coming across the top of the
hour but i'd love to give you a chance
to maybe say a little bit about either
where you're going with this work and or
what your
your next work is i know you work you've
been affiliated with the institute for
the future and they've been
uh they've been supporting this work to
some level but i'd love to hear kind of
where
what's your ecosystem of this work and
and where do you see it going next
oh i i want to keep pursuing this quite
honestly this is um
i mean i i really as i mentioned at the
very top of the video i mean i have been
i've been a futurist for 20 years i have
been
uh basically out for about 20 years uh
and i'm finally feeling i'm finally
feeling those those converge
um i wan i want to explore both
both queer foresight so i'm really
starting to understand what are the
forces
what are the future forces that will
disproportionately disrupt
the lies of lgbt people um i mean we're
talking we're talking automation
i think will disproportionately disrupt
um
you know these natural natural resource
depletion
uh will disproportionately disrupt
poverty hunger um
and then and so that we can begin to
future proof future
future-proof my community future-proof
um
us as a as a subculture um but then also
to explore
really to explore this querying as a as
a as a toolkit querying as a mindset
um i mean i'm going to get i i
as much as there may be some trouble
brewing in the in the uh in the comments
right now i'm going to get in trouble
for even implying that queerness could
be um
could be you uh turn it into into a
toolkit or a utility
uh i think that but i i actually think
there's
so much there's a lot that queerness has
through struggle uh to struggle through
through
pain through violence through death has
mastered
um and that i think needs to be shared
and can
help a lot of other people going forward
so
uh i think uh queer futures uh
in short i think is you know hopefully
that is
hopefully that carries me through uh as
a futurist
next well i'm i'm reminded when you say
that that um you know one of my favorite
principles of of longevity uh
which was kind of coined around the
discovery of the bristlecone pine tree
the longest lived single species was
that adversity breeds longevity and that
things that live in the most difficult
environments are often the most
long-lived and we see this i think with
institutions
cultures um biology and and i'm hoping
that at least
through some of the adversity some good
things are going to be
coming out of it and thank you very much
for joining us
um and look forward to hearing more of
your work in the future
thank you thank you very much for
hosting me thank you and i want to thank
you our audience for joining us um the
recording of this will be up in
perpetuity um
and um and i hope for that you can join
us for some of our future talks we have
some amazing
things planned for the rest of 2021
which i'm hoping
will even bring us back to some
in-person
events at some point in the future so
thank you very much
[Music]
you